have you noticed that nobody uses
computers anymore okay all right before
you get mad and leave a nasty comment
obviously computers are still extremely
popular literally over a billion people
still own computers and hundreds of
millions use them every day for work
school and entertainment personally I'm
very much part of this group as I'm
running two computers as we speak just
to record this but that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about a larger
macro shift away from computers take
internet traffic stats for example every
month Google gets 35.5 billion visits
but 77% of those visits or 27.5 billion
of them are from mobile and this trend
holds across the board in fact several
websites skew even more towards
smartphones YouTube is 85% smartphones
Reddit is 81% duck Dogo is 90% Wikipedia
is 80% and certain other sites well
they're around 95% scrolling through
this list you'd be pretty hard oppressed
to find websites that are actually
majority desktop and usually those are
older websites that are larly used by
older people for example Yahoo is only
43% mobile and Microsoft online is only
21% to mobile but putting aside those
exceptions it's clear that the SK is
overwhelmingly toward smartphones which
if you think about it makes sense
nowadays people do everything from their
smartphones whether it's investing
buying a car buying a house reading the
news you name it really the only time
that most people still use computers is
for productivity you know if your job or
School requires Microsoft Office or
coding or 3D modeling or a bunch of
virtual meetings you get the idea but
putting aside productivity people tend
to do everything on their smartphones
but why obviously phones are more
convenient on the go but when you're not
on the go computers can accomplish a lot
more yet the stat that suggests that
unless people have to use their
computers they don't so why in the world
does nobody use computers anymore and
what does this mean for the future of a
desktop versus
[Music]
mobile obviously this hasn't always been
the case as smartphones haven't even
been around for two decades at this
point but with that being said that also
means that it hasn't taken long for this
trend to take cold so what happened well
I think this trend can largely be
explained by three overarching factors
starting with demographics you see this
trend has less to do with computer users
suddenly using their smartphones more
and more to do with younger people just
never using computers I mean just look
at the stats the average person spends 3
hours and 15 minutes every day on their
smartphones which is already a lot of
time Millennials aren't too much worse
coming in slightly higher at 3.7 hours
per day
but do you want to guess how much time
gen Z spends on their smartphones every
day maybe four five 6 hours well it's
actually up to 9 hours a lot of these
people have rigorous full-time jobs and
they still have insane amounts of screen
time basically if they're not actively
working on something that requires a
computer or sleeping they're on their
phones now you could go down the whole
Rabbit Hole of how healthy is this but
that's outside the scope of this video
what we're really concerned about is how
this affect smartphone usage and clearly
it affects it enormously the average
person only uses their computer for 2
hours and 51 minutes per day but that's
just the first reason which brings us
into the vastly different context of
mobile and desktop usage when you use
computers you naturally tend to be
working on something more intense that
requires singular Focus so even though
you might end up spending hours on a
computer in any given session it's
likely that you only visited a a handful
of websites or programs if you're a
coder for example even if you spent 10
hours in front of a computer it's likely
that your entire screen time only
consisted of slack Visual Studio Zoom
stack Overflow and Gmail in contrast if
you spent 10 hours in front of a
smartphone it's likely that your screen
time was far more diverse sure you might
have only visited offerings from Google
meta and Amazon but the number of
individual Pages who visited would
likely be in the hundreds if not over a
thousand if you're scrolling Tik Tok for
example you're essentially visiting a
new page every 5 Seconds when you swipe
even if you're just surfing the web
you're much more likely to bounce around
in fact the average time spent on a
desktop site is 40% longer than the
average time spent on a mobile site so
again considering that it's no surprise
why internet traffic heavily leans in
the favor of mobile but all of that
really only applies to Western countries
which brings us into the third reason
the developing world it's only in
Western countries trees where almost
everyone has access to both a smartphone
and a computer and it's up to their mood
as to what they use when we look at the
developing World though people can often
only afford one or the other and when
put in that situation they
overwhelmingly choose to go with a
smartphone in terms of numbers there are
roughly 1.4 billion Windows PCS
worldwide if you throw in mac and Linux
on top of that that number might go to
1.7 or 1.8 billion but do you want to
guess how many smartphones are out there
the answer is 6.94 billion or 85% of the
entire world population yeah I don't
think that requires any additional
explanation so essentially internet
traffic is dominated by smartphones due
to gen Z smartphone users bouncing
around far more often and the developing
World At Large but all of that only
tells the quantitative side of the story
which still leaves the question of
why
here's the thing given the data we've
discussed it's obvious that gen Z and
the developing world are skewing the
data towards
smartphones but there's more to this
story than just that because I don't
think that that's a forced reality
virtually every Zoomer has access to
both a smartphone and a computer so the
fact that they spend 9 hours a day on a
smartphone is very much a choice Also
regarding the developing world even if
you gave them all computers right now I
suspect that their use would still
primarily skew towards smartphones and
for this I suspect that the explanation
primarily centers on the vastly
different adoption curves of the
computer and the smartphone the
traditional computer can be traced all
the way back to 1822 but the average
person didn't get a PC till the 1990s
and really the 2000s you could say that
this was because computers were simply
too expensive before the '90s but you
could ALS also say the same thing about
a car cars are super expensive but the
average person has been getting cars
since the Model T days because the need
outweighs the high price for computers
however that was simply not the case
because computers were initially not
designed for the average person it was
designed for corporations governments
and universities to conduct research do
mathematical analysis and create
communication and storage infrastructure
the average person in the' 70s and ' 80s
had a no use for any of that so buying a
computer for personal use was more of a
novelty than anything the fact that
computers eventually became applicable
to the average person was more of a
byproduct of innovation as opposed to
the focus of innovation with smartphones
however it was the exact opposite at
most you can say that the first
smartphone was created in 1992 but
smartphones really had no utility in
society for businesses or people until
the iPhone and as for the iPhone well
this was specifically designed for the
consumer everything from the
over-the-top animations and intuitive
gestures to the seemingly infinite App
Store and inviting UI it was all
designed as a luxury purchase for the
average person and this core difference
has set the stage for everything that
came about on both platforms and you
don't even have to look that far to spot
these differences take Google for
instance something that came out during
the computer era originally Google was a
Stanford research project meant to help
people research it just so happened that
everyday people eventually found utility
in Consulting Google on a regular basis
now in contrast take a look at mobile
era services like uber Airbnb Snapchat
Instagram Tik Tok Robin Hood door Dash
and so on each and every one of these
Services were designed from the groundup
to maximize on consumption from all
fronts whether that's screen time
engagement Revenue market share you name
it so from that perspect perspective
it's really not surprising why people
prefer to spend a lot more time on a
device that was created for consumption
as opposed to a device that was created
for utility and over time this
Association has been engraved in
people's minds this is probably why you
tend to use your laptop at your desk but
your phone or your tablet on your bed or
couch the bottom line is that people use
computers because it's a utility that
they need while they use smartphones
because it's a luxury that they want now
of course you could argue that in the
Modern Age smartphones are very much
also a need and I completely agree with
that but I would also argue that want
still plays a far larger role with
smartphones than it does with computers
that's why people are far more likely to
purchase a flagship smartphone as
opposed to a flagship computer even if
prices were the same so that kind of
explains why nobody uses computers
anymore both from a quantitative
standpoint and a qualitative standpoint
but that still leaves one question what
what does this mean for the future of
desktop versus
mobile corporations are well aware of
this trend and that's why they shifted
their entire Focus towards smartphones
this includes building better mobile
websites better mobile apps and of
course spending a lot lot more on mobile
ads I mean just to look at this chart in
2013 desktop ad spend stood at $32
billion while mobile ad spend stood at
just $10 billion or a third of desktop
ad spend by 2015 though they were both
at roughly $30 billion and by 2019 mobo
had grown to 65 billion while desktop
was down to 25 billion and as you would
probably guess this disparity has only
grown even further thanks to the
pandemic as of 2023 Mobile accounts for
70% of programmatic digital ad spend
within the us while desktops and laptops
only account for a mere
13% doeses this this mean that computers
are just dead and companies will stop
offering desktop platforms no of course
not while people prefer to spend the
majority of their time on mobile devices
they still very much value having a
desktop option as well for example with
banking I probably only log into the
desktop portal a few times a year while
I log into the mobile portal almost
every day but I still very much value
the desktop portal because it makes
downloading account statements and
filing taxes a lot easier similarly if
if I'm watching Netflix it's always on
my iPad or TV but if I were to manage my
membership or cancel my subscription I'd
probably do it on the computer and I get
the feeling that this is how most people
feel let me know down below if you agree
with that being said I suspect that
services will become more and more
mobile centered while desktop offerings
become more and more geared towards
managing these services or doing tasks
that aren't easy on mobile desktops will
of course also continue to be EXT
extremely relevant when it comes to
productivity but that's why the internet
is now dominated by smartphones another
industry that I seen an extremely
interesting evolution is TVs which seem
to be infinitely getting cheaper check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next
one